[Music]
work do your plumbing
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to and do
I really have to we have to this is the
mummy with Tom Cruise
this was supposed to be the big start to
what else a cinematic universe one
universal one to create with its classic
monster movies because everything has to
be a goddamn universe now Christ I'm
surprised the Teletubbies don't have a
Cinematic Universe don't give them ideas
oh shit that the film bombed throwing
their future dark universe films into
question I really wanted to talk about
this movie because in some respect this
comes full circle
what okay it's a very shittily drawn
circle but it's still a circle did you
just make up the word shittily my point
is Universal invented the shared
universe concept in the 40s crossovers
versus Team ups all these were
originally done with the classic
Universal Monsters Marvel and everybody
else is technically copying what they
started somewhere down the line that fad
faded but as films like Freddy vs. Jason
civil war and Batman vs. Superman became
popular suddenly Universal wanted to
jump back onboard
so now ironically Universal is copying
Marvel and all these other films
forgetting that Universal was the one
that came up with this idea to begin
with and that's all this movie is a copy
a copy of every overused cliché and
current cinematic universe is trying to
set up the next five movies rather than
focusing on making one good one I
actually wanted to see this movie
succeed because I want the Universal
Monsters to continue in some way they're
not as popular nowadays as they should
be so it's important to bring them back
in the public minds it's like Batman or
James Bond we all have our favorite
actors who played the roles but we still
accept different versions and the best
ones can create new timeless
interpretations does this film do that I
think you know the I know the answer
let's dive into the dark universes mummy
look at this they're already declaring
it the dark universe who we're so
excited there's gonna be more of
something that we don't even know if we
like yet followed by a quote because
they just want a quote yeah they always
do that to make films seem more
important hey how about this for a more
fitting quote it opens with medieval
knights oh god its transformers v killer
with underperforming ticket sales too
late
wait now we're in present-day England
does this film even know what film it is
well we got a show Russell Crowe is in
this movie just to cut immediately away
from him
oh now we're in Egypt thank God I almost
forgot this was a mummy movie the story
hasn't even been set up yeah and there's
already two scenes you can cut to
someone pasted over a draft of a script
without a racing part of the other
trapped princess ominous beautiful
cunning and ruthless The Mummy this time
is not in hotep but rather a princess ah
Manette which is a welcome change before
all we had was the Bride of Frankenstein
and maybe Dracula's daughter it was kind
of a sausage fest you know in most
incarnations of the story there's
usually a mummy princess this is just
putting the mummy princess in the
spotlight making her the main monster
she has her own unique style and would
look cool in a lineup of other monsters
so this is not a bad starting point the
problem is everything else about her
makes no goddamn sense in this one it's
not a forbidden love that forces her to
give up her soul it's because a baby
brother is born stopping her from
becoming Queen so she uses the same
spark effect even literally just saw to
quote get revenge yeah that's how they
put it now in revenge she made a choice
to embrace evil revenge for what I don't
know revenge against the baby for
literally being born but okay she kills
the kid and the mother and the Pharaoh
what happens next
Yuval bring
the god of death into our world in the
body of a mortal man together they would
take their vengeance upon humanity from
I have no idea what this chick is about
first she wants to be queen then kill
her brother then Blanca demon thank you
the demon to release the demon to take
over the world
that's like saying after Bruce Wayne's
parents died he wanted to become Batman
open a flower shop become a disco dancer
and create three new ice creams one
motivation is enough after becoming The
Enchantress she stopped before she can
unleash her devil boyfriend or however I
was supposed to work and she's mummified
the body carried far from Egypt yeah no
shit far it's friggin Iraq they make it
look like a small stroll about Iraq's a
little bit of a skip but not far enough
to keep an infestation of Tom Cruise's
away he plays sergeant Rick Morton who's
supposed to be doing advanced recon we
are not looters we are liberators of
precious antiquities now usually I'd say
who cares just get to the mummy already
but you know what he's representing
America's troops so I do care I want to
see how they're represented here is
what's down here treasure commando know
where we are and we'll do 20 years and
Leavenworth for looting yes on your
quarters you disrespectful shit bags I
don't get it why can't it just be
archeologists like all the other films
there is nothing wrong with that the
ethical question of how much do you
uncover for science and/or greed fits
perfectly with that scenario but here
disobeying orders risking prison and all
just to sell artifacts on the black
market seems hugely disrespectful when
it's a sergeant in the army
look I know not every soldier is a saint
but this is the main character and I'm
just gonna take a wild guess and say
they don't write him superhuman or
complex are you kidding me he's one of
the deepest characters in cinema just
listen to this incredible banter when
he's breaking into enemy lines to find
treasure
hey they almost got every generic saying
how about they don't make them like they
used to when some you lose some
I didn't sign up for this here we go
again well beloved of too many layers to
count at least we get a kernel who's
trying to offset Cruz's awful character
too bad he's more like an angry
Commissioner stereotyped two assholes
from long-range reconnaissance stealing
whatever isn't nailed down we have no
idea what could be down there you're
getting in the hole Widow him me oh and
he's also a dumbass I'll be right here
holding the ropes I'd give a damn hole
veil oh man wait a minute he just gave a
long speech about why they're
untrustworthy and now he's sending only
them with this archaeologist who Cruz
literally just admitted he slept with as
I had him in my hotel room three nights
ago in Baghdad so just to clarify the
mummy says the Army is full of horny
idiots and thieves and you know it's a
credible source because the guy who
wrote transformers 2 is saying it you're
the devil's taint movie they roam around
the tomb after partaking in some amazing
chemistry fantastic and they find the
sarcophagus submerged in mercury
there's nut cream dripping from the
ceiling well that's different
the ancient Egyptians believed that weak
and evil spirit now we know better stuff
will kill you
yeah after it makes you crazy kind of
like what not reading a script before
you sign on to a franchise does after
finding all minutes tomb there's
suddenly attacked by bugs yeah remember
how they were a big thing in the brenden
fraiser one well now they're back to
wreak havoc
okay huh so much for that
so Cruz has a weird vision of ah Manette
just before this hilarious scene tell
Greenway to get this thing out of here
or he's gonna have to explain what he
left me behind do it it's funny because
she backed up in a weird way no it is it
I don't know that they take possession
of their tomb and bring it to their base
is there really no better way to
transport that but apparently Cruz's
friend gets possessed by the mummy and
starts killing people don't make me
shoot you again a tea style I'm turning
the gun I'll do it oh my god that's so
cool I want to do it again
but the film wants to rip off Hitchcock
- why not it's ripped off from
everything else
okay to the films credit it is kind of
cool seeing them fly around in the plane
you know they combined the antigravity
techniques from Apollo 13 with a
spinning said to create a really neat
combo of effects too bad the plane looks
just as fake as the one in Superman
Returns my movie bitch laters the play
pressures but crews mysteriously
survives without a scratch on him and
big shock he gets to show off his body
again
yes Cruz you're very cool somebody said
that you can stop trying now cops come
across the crash plane and now it's just
waiting for the jump scare okay I hate
waiting for these I'm gonna go take a
piss just tell me what it happened so I
can pretend like I haven't seen it a
million times
will do
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my god so scary
[Music]
hey Doug Walker here just telling you
real quick we are returning to Rhode
Island comic-con and this time I'm
bringing my brother Rob along now the
reason I'm making this announcement in
the middle of the video is because last
year they were saying they didn't know
if they'd want to invite Internet people
to such a big kind so we really need you
guys to come to this con and say hello
to us
the Khans amazing I mean just look at
this guest list there's so many good
people here but you can see there's not
that many internet people we had a great
turnout last year we will have a great
turnout this year too to show a lot of
these cons to internet people are not
going away it's only growing and you can
help that so hopefully we'll see you
guys there take care he transforms the
cops into the walking duds as we cut
back to Cruz with Jenny did you there's
not a single scratch what he's just
going through an incredible experience
coming back from the dead which is
essentially what this entire film is
about how's he gonna react to it
god this movie gets it but his friend
Val seems to be a possessed ghost that
only Cruz can see why Cruz is already
possessed we don't need another one I
don't even get it
why is one a ghost and one invincible
there's too many different rules you
know I always thought I had a chance for
their what how do you squander that
there's mercury in that too oh I get it
now it's so they can steal from American
Werewolf in London and that's the word
steal just in my head it's in my head no
it's not I'm going completely crazy
please believe me I'm cursed NIC until
the werewolf curse is lifted this is
gonna get a lot worse I'm not having a
nice time here it doesn't come off as a
spoof or self-aware it's not even really
a common cliche it's just stealing in
fact there's too many people under the
Mummy's control Tom Cruise his friend
and these zombie cops all seem to be
under different types of possessions it
makes it harder to get an idea how this
mummy works or even what to be afraid of
if Freddy Krueger got me I know I'd be
in a dream and he torture me if Dracula
got me I know I'd be bidden and turned
into a vampire
but if this mummy got me I don't know I
might be a zombie I might be invincible
I might only be able to talk through a
mirror but wait there's even more we've
been searching for the dagger of
center-set is the Egyptian god of death
the dagger and stone together had the
power to give us a physical form but now
we have to worry about the god of death
too
the movies called The Mummy why not just
focus on the mummy yeah like in
Frankenstein the monster is all you need
it's not like the monster and Satan are
going to go throw little girls in ponds
one is enough speaking of which where's
our monster the film's almost halfway
over and we barely seen her well cruise
gets a vision to find her in a church
where she finally reveals herself right
after that same spark effect from
earlier film trying to set itself on
fire what is that she uses her minions
to trap him and she
finds the blade to sacrifice him to
release the god of death so she just
sends to the blade was in that statue I
guess but she also realizes the stone is
missing wait she could sense that the
blade was there but couldn't sense that
the stone wasn't attached
in fact why did she take it out earlier
to prepare why did you wait for crews to
get there isn't that not thinking ahead
look there's a perfectly logical
explanation for all this Jenny comes in
to save him but much like the movie
though they're going around in circles
and her minions send them off a cliff
that seems to be the one thing this
movie knows how to do well crash and
burn yep but armed men take her down
with grappling hooks are thrilling mummy
everybody nothing can stop her except
wires with something sharp at the end of
them
they she was just sent an army of maples
after her Cruz is taken to a secret
location in London where we get cameos
and jars The Creature from the Black
Lagoon is hand a vampire skull look how
are the duck is in the back and Russell
Crowe the Nick Fury of this movie in the
role of who else dr. Jekyll I would like
if I may 5 stories just stick to one
this is the middle of the film which
would normally be where all the
exposition goes but we've already had so
much exposition already
we're tired out even The Mummy herself
starts telling us stories and the same
scattered flashbacks play this won't be
slow in all the wrong ways and fast in
all the wrong ways but wait here's a big
surprise Jenny was working for this
organization the whole time why is that
a big surprise because he looks
surprised what was I supposed to tell
you would you even have believed me
she's so boring we barely know what
she's like how am I supposed to know if
this is in character or not well who we
know she doesn't want the mummy
dissected so she can know more about her
world so she tries to talk to her for
about two minutes what you truly
wish to know what I have seen yes and
you will when I kill you
Wow she makes one weak thread and she's
like I don't need to know about your
world anymore she's tough bones you
think so
I have no idea she's boring welcome to a
new world of gods and monsters that's
the closest thing to an homage you fair
boys are getting dicks but crow reveals
that he wants to kill Crusoe he never
becomes the god of death and he's
surprisingly blunt about it certain
sacrifices must be made
Henry are you planning on killing him
mr. Morton here essentially killed
himself when he severed the barrier
chain one but two stone in the dagger
and stabbed him with it the dagger will
allow scent to enter his body do you
know he's still in the room
right he was stabbed precisely
intentionally I don't know it's more
stupid crow admitting he's gonna kill
crews our crews just standing there
listening to him he's acting more like
he just heard a bad pay package for his
cell phone no matter what I do you are
going to die I'm not interested in that
at all I'm not going anywhere until I
get a no credit lease-to-own agreement
Jekyll starts to turn into Hyde though
are you sure I think that's just how he
is when he's drunk and they fight while
The Mummy possesses someone else to help
her escape
younger man Cruz you're two years older
than him can you kill your ego for just
a few seconds they escape of course but
the mummy hunts them down with all her
powers
screams buildings blow up people run
yeah yeah pretty generic shit this
doesn't even feel like a theatrical film
feels like a sci-fi Channel movie of the
week but hey what they have the face in
the storm it's not the original mummy
movie but it's a mummy movie they even
have the Brendan Fraser moment of
somebody making a stupid face while
stating the obvious what was that oh
that just felt like a line that was put
in for the trailer so I just threw that
in there isn't all of this just a
trailer already for future films though
so now she's using the corpses of
medieval knights to chase after him
zombie Knights in London remember when
this used to be a mummy movie Oh me
neither he swims through a Castlevania
level to fine ama net is waiting I swear
his reaction here is the exact same
reaction of all the people who saw this
on the big screen
answer and all two of you had that
reaction but oh no Jenny is dead god no
not her she had so much character please
actually most of the climax is just Tom
Cruise getting his ass kicked it's more
funny than suspenseful but he decides
out of nowhere that he does want to be
the god of death why so we can have
literally four eyes but it doesn't take
him over or something I don't know it's
not very well explained and he uses his
new powers to defeat her oh now that was
the move of someone who just blew up
buildings a slap look out for the mummy
she might slap you what the hell
happened to the powers you had before
you dummy mummy he defeats her and turns
into black heart from Ghost Rider to
bring Jenny back seemingly fighting the
evil that's inside him but an even more
important resurrection takes place our
comic relief fail thank you for bringing
me back to life and everything that come
on admit it
Cruz was more in love with him than he
was with her then he rides off with all
his power leaving the door open whether
or not he'll use them for good or evil
um shouldn't that be more of dr.
Jekyll's thing you know he's in the
movie right isn't this kind of a
redundant idea with Cruise's character
what even is Cruz now he's not any of
the classic monsters is he the new mummy
is the other mummy dead why should I be
excited for any of this
you couldn't even tease the future
movies right and this movie's sole
purpose is to tease other movies a good
tease would be building up the Wolfman
because we know what that is and can get
excited for it when you see Thor's
hammer at the end of a movie you know
Thor is coming when you see the Joker
card at the end of a movie you know the
Joker is coming but what am I supposed
to do with this think Tom Cruise now has
epic farts that can cause sandstorms I'm
not excited I'm confused and pissed off
this movie is terrible that it friggin
is aside from him becoming bland Helsing
I don't know what kind of world this is
trying to set up it focuses too much on
planning ahead rather than focusing on
what's right in front of you you can't
grow a garden if you can't figure out
how to plant your first flower the
reason to do a reboot is to do something
different or improve on it the classic
Universal crossovers had their faults
Frankenstein Meets The Wolfman worked
well when it was two monsters but when
they started throwing Dracula in and
house of Frankenstein house of Dracula
it's starting to become a mess because
they couldn't really figure out how to
write all the monsters into one film but
this is not an improvement it follows
every modern trend without creating
anything unique I'd compare it to one of
the main jokes in the mockumentary
spinal tap the band is following every
popular style of music the hippie flower
phase 80's glam rock phase and every
time they join the trend they're just a
bit too late The Mummy follows the
zombie trend action trend superhero
trend it throws everything in the pot
but not in a fun self-aware way it's
like it's really trying hard to cast out
a big net and be the most popular thing
possible it's overly confident that this
is the first chapter in a cinematic
universe when really this epic
first step is an epic misstep
man that was our review of the mummy and
you were right nerd
listen nearly as bad as I thought it
would be I don't remember saying that
you're right because it was okay it's
all right once you calm down critic why
don't you watch something good for a
change yeah I guess I could I even left
a new movie on your desk it's based on
an anime that's supposed to be really
good huh you did I didn't notice that
there the whole time how strange and
yeah other good things about that anime
yeah so obviously the movie must be good
right yeah that's sound logic thanks a
lot nerd you're not such a bad guy after
all
I'm really gonna enjoy watching this
[Music]
[Applause]
you want to stab me precisely
intentionally
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out and this week we are doing the
American Lung Association this is the
leading organization working to save
lives by improving lung health and
preventing lung disease through research
education and advocacy their work is
focused on five strategic imperatives to
defeat lung cancer to improve the air we
breathe to reduce the burden of lung
disease on individuals and their
families to accelerate fundraising and
to enhance organizational effectiveness
to support the urgency of their mission
whether it's searching for cures to lung
disease or fighting for laws that
protect the air we breathe the work of
the American Lung Association helps to
save lives every day for more than a
hundred and ten years they've led the
fight for healthy lungs and healthy air
and today their work is more important
than ever if you go to their site or
their YouTube page you can see in great
detail not only how they helped but who
they help definitely drop by and show
your support for a future filled with
easy breathing
you
[Music]